The music world
is mourning the death of singer
Aaron Carter.
The 34 year old was found dead
in his California home yesterday.
Authorities say
he was found in his bathtub
but a cause of death remains unknown.
Carter rose to fame
at a very young age,
known for his music and acting career,
but battled mental health
issues and addiction in his later years.
Camilla Bernal
has more on his life and legacy.
He's going to be the flash kid
on the block.
Dad pop in the
with the right stuff from a young age.
Aaron Carter was in the limelight.
The younger brother of Backstreet
Boys, Nick Carter, had his own success
as a child.
Pop singer
Songs
like I Want Candy and Crush On You
raised him to fame.
Candy Aaron Carter died on Saturday.
Authorities giving no information
about a possible cause of death.
Did they go now?
His debut
album, Aaron
Carter, was released in 1997.
He had already performed
as the opening act
for the Backstreet Boys.
Carter was also known for his roles on TV
shows like Lizzie McGuire
and Seventh Heaven.
He was also on his family's reality
TV series House of Carters
right here in 2017.
Carter came out as bisexual
and later received
an outpouring of love and support
from his fans
and other celebrities
living in the South him.
In 2018 he released his fifth and final
album Love
Over the years,
Carter publicly
talked about addiction struggles.
Here he is on an episode of The Doctors
in 2019.
The reason why I went to rehab
is for huffing
aerosols,
dust cans,
That's why I went.
I lied to you and I lied to you.
And I'm sorry.
And I'm here to make amends.
He also opened up about his battle
with multiple mental health issues,
including multiple personality disorder,
schizophrenia, acute
anxiety, and manic depression.
That's my truth.
Get your father for
the fans
constantly supported him
and are now remembering the pop star,
many on social media
saying they're saddened
and shocked
and sending prayers to the family.
He leaves behind his 11th month old son,
Prince.
Erin Carter was 34 years old.
Oh, my gosh.
That is so sad.
Jimmy live here now.
Thank you so much.
And of course, we have just heard now
just moments ago from his brother
Nick Carter
posting on Instagram
saying in part,
my heart has been broken today.
Now you get a chance to finally
have some peace
you could never find here on Earth.
God please take care of my baby brother.